Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
With Matthew McConaughey sometimes.
Oh no, you're not Matthew McConaughey?
Yeah, we don't have
him here for that part.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
We are talking to Matthew McConaughey.
Expanding the circle.
It is not an interview.
We wanted it to be a conversation.
We wanted it to be an extension
of what Ear Biscuits has become,
even though it is exceptional
that we decided to do an interview.
And we didn't do it just because,
well, he's so famous,
we gotta talk to him.
It was that. And it was more than that.
It was personal for us, honestly.
We're not about to make Ear Biscuits
anything other than what it is.
Right.
For for the most part,
we kind of broke the seal on, okay,
we can bring in a guest sometimes.
But the reason that we decided to do this
is it goes back to,
I guess it was beginning of 2020,
is when we were actually,
we were given Matthew's book Greenlights,
which is something that
happens pretty often, right.
Celebrities write books
and then their team
send them out to other celebrities
or people who have an audience.
So they might read them
and talk about them.
so we ended up getting quite a few books
and I saw this, his book come in
and I was like, oh, this is interesting.
This is more of like a
memoir kind of thing.
But I didn't immediately like say, okay,
I'm gonna start reading this thing.
It was my good friend's Lance and Lacey,
of Beard and Lady,
who make all the grooming
products from Mythical.
Oh, really?
They live a life of adventure.
And they live a life
of embracing new ideas
and new challenges.
And following those things, for instance.
With gusto.
Deciding to revitalize
a historic haunted hotel
in Arkansas and turn it into
a hotel that you can visit.
That's like the latest
thing that they've done.
They're always doing something like that.
We wouldn't have our grooming products
if it wasn't for them hatching that idea.
Yeah.
And so when they said,
have you listened to Greenlights yet?
And Jesse and I have a
text thread with them.
That is very much that have
you watched this thing?
I told you when we went home for Christmas
or whenever it was, for the summer,
they were like you got to watch this.
Yeah, they knew the stuff to watch.
I watched Bo Burnham: Insides with them.
Like I waited specifically
to watch that with them.
But anyway.
So, the recommendation coming from them.
It was like, all right, I'll do it.
Yeah and so.
Did you read or listen to it?
I listened to it because
I've kind of moved
almost exclusively into audio books?
There's not a small amount of shame
that comes with that,
just for me personally,
because I have this bias towards reading.
But I can do anything
else while I'm listening.
So I just ended up listening
to all kinds of books,
like multiple books a month
is like my pace now, right?
So.
And then you started talking
to me about aspects of it,
like just how his approach
to being, expressing himself
and being creative and
going after his muse,
Well, in 90% percent of it.
And the principles of it.
Well, 90% to begin with
was, man, you can't believe
this thing that happened
to Matthew McConaughey.
Right, right. Just a great story.
And you can't believe the
way that Matthew McConaughey
decides to tell you the story.
Everybody knows Matthew
McConaughey at this point.
So you can imagine how he's
going to tell this story.
But so listening to him do it
in his very McConaughey way
is just, it was a treat.
And I was resisting telling you the story,
you know how when you get into something,
you want to just tell people the stories.
And you're like Mr. Spoiler
reverse to the nth degree.
So I had to be like, well,
there's a story about
him going to Australia
and it's like, okay,
well, I've been Australia.
You can't give away too much,
but then you ended up getting into it.
He went as a foreign exchange student,
you should say that.
Yeah.
I didn't listen to it
for a number of weeks
because I had other stuff.
But then I had hit this dry spell
and I was like, I need something.
And I started listening
to it two weeks ago
and then after I was almost
done with it is when,
they were like, hey, he
wants to come on your show.
We're like, I think we
gotta make this happen
because it resonated with us so much.
Yeah.
So as you'll see, we turned it into us,
getting what we needed out
of it and our own purposes.
It's not really an interview, as you can.
I would advise most interviewers
to not begin interviews
by just telling stories about
themselves, like we did,
it was kind of like what
Chris Farley used to do on SNL
when he was.
Remember that time when.
No, we didn't do that.
No, but I had a feeling,
not knowing Matthew
personally, but knowing of him
and in listening to the
book and I had a feeling
that he would just get right into the.
Yeah.
He's a let's have a campfire
conversation kind of guy.
And so he just, he stepped right in here
and it would have been nice
to have an actually at the table,
but you know what.
He's still on video chat,
It is what it is.
So if you watch the Video
version, it's there.
All right, let's get to it.
But first we always want to encourage you
to go to a mythical.com to rep your boys.
Do you have any clue what's over there?
If you haven't been over there,
There's a lot of stuff.
In a couple of weeks,
it's gonna be new stuff.
So go to mythical.com, browse it.
You don't have to make any commitments.
And if you find yourself
purchasing something,
then thank you.
And if you want something,
things come and things go.
There's actually the last chance section,
where things that will go
away and never come back.
We've put that all together
in one nice little section for you.
Grab it.
So you won't complain about not being able
to get something in the last
chance section, mythical.com.
It's great to meet you.
We don't typically have
guests on our podcast,
but we both read and
listened to Greenlights
and we love good stories.
And you got some good stories, man.
And we loved it.
It's been many moons
since we have had a conversation
outside of just the two of us talking,
because we figured out
we've got quite a bit
that we can just talk
about to each other about.
Yeah.
But we both connected with your book
and I mean, lots of people
have connected with your book
and in a big way, but something
about your stage of life,
your story kind of coming
from small town South.
There was a lot that we could relate to.
And there's a lot that's on our minds
that I think selfishly,
when you start talking
about legacy in Greenlights.
Yeah.
That's like we're having so
many conversations about that
and also on this podcast.
So I think selfishly,
we just want to pick
your brain a little bit
and kind of unpack some more of that.
But first, when it comes to these stories.
Right.
And just relating to that.
There's a couple of
uncanny, uncanny parallels.
I love you're talking about your mom,
basically telling you to
plagiarize the poem that then.
I won.
And then you won.
I won whatever, the seventh
grade poetry contest
Yeah. Because I mean talk about, yeah,
because does the poem
mean something to you?
Yeah, I understand it.
So you like it?
Yeah. It brings up a feeling in you Matt.
Yeah, it says if all
that I would want to do
would be to sit and talk
to you, would you listen?
That's like, yeah mom.
So you understand that?
Yeah, then write that.
Well, it's Anne Ashberry
No, but as I said,
you sign your name
because you understand it.
That was her reason.
It means something to you, it's yours.
Now, here's my version of my mom.
We had this poster contest.
County-wide.
County-wide, Harnett
County, anti-drug message.
And I told my mom,
now my mom worked at the
public health department
and there was a pamphlet for everything.
And so she would come,
that's how I learned about
sex, through a pamphlet.
She brought home a pamphlet.
She said, well, Link,
there's an anti-drug one
and look, there's a picture right here.
And it says,
there are lots of fun things
to do instead of drugs.
And then it's a guy holding
all these other things,
like badminton thing.
Yeah.
And like an art art easel
and stuff like that.
And so she basically said, draw that.
But here's the thing about my mom,
I don't even think she
knew what plagiarism was.
Yeah, she didn't. There was no process.
Well, she explained it to make it okay.
She didn't have a pithy tenet
that you can prescribe in your book.
For her, it was just very innocent.
Right, right, right.
This is a great idea,
Why don't you just do exactly that?
Right, right, right.
And I did it and I won.
By a long shot,
And you won. Okay
I won baby.
Here you go.
He won the whole county, which.
I believed it.
And listen, as his best
friend at the time.
What grade was that?
Fourth or fifth?
I had no idea.
I didn't tell anybody.
I thought you had done dug really deep.
Yeah.
Deeper than ever.
I still have it.
I have a laminated poster
of this in my office
that somebody mailed me.
With a blue ribbon on it.
Yeah.
And now the other thing
that was a bit of an uncanny parallel.
So my dad is a bit of a
larger than life character
at any time throughout my life.
Even when I felt like I
was afraid of nothing,
I've always been afraid of him, right?
Right. Yeah.
And in a good way, the good fear.
And so by the time that we
were seniors in high school,
in Buies Creek, North Carolina,
where nobody that we knew
had taken any sort of entertainment path.
Our idea of being an entertainer
was the guy who would come
to the middle school dances
and do, he was either a DJ
or he could be a magician.
That was the guy.
I've seen him do both at once.
And so, but we had this idea,
we want to go to film school.
And I had that conversation with my dad
that you had with your dad.
When you called him up and said,
I'm thinking about going to film school.
And that was pretty built up for you.
Yeah.
You kind of had to like breathe
into that moment, right?
Very much so.
It was a moment where
I wasn't sleeping well
at the idea of going to law school.
So that was keeping me up at night.
Then it was weeks of
sharing stories and stuff.
I'd written with my buddy,
Rob Bindler, who was NYU,
who was the only film guy I knew at all.
And plus he was at Longview, Texas.
He didn't watch many films there either.
So I'm sending him stuff in New York.
He's writing back, going,
man, this is pretty good, this is good.
And I knew he'd give me an honest opinion.
And then I get the confidence.
Then I find the book, The
Greatest Salesman In The World,
the Og Mandino book.
Sometimes a piece of art or a book
will find you or a person
will share something with you.
And you're like, they've
been reading my mail.
Yeah.
This is direct line.
This was written for me right now,
I have no question about it,
when we have that clarity,
whether it's true or
not, it is true, right?
Yeah.
So that book found me,
gave me the courage to say,
that's what I'm doing.
And then I had to plan out
when the best time to call dad was
since he was paying tuition.
So I say, like I said in the book,
I picked that Tuesday
night, seven o'clock,
he's home from work.
He's already eaten dinner,
he's having a beer with mom on the couch,
best time to get it.
Yeah.
Not Monday, Tuesday.
And I called him 19:36
pm and laid it on him.
And he gave me that great response.
Okay, more that yes, don't half ass it,
but go on about your story about.
Well.
You coming out of North Carolina.
The thing is that I must have not,
I did not plan as well as you did,
because when I told my dad,
dad, I'm thinking about going,
Link and I are thinking
about going to film school.
Right.
It had been years since
we had done the blood oath
and said, we're gonna
create something together.
And like, we had really colluded
and we had each other.
Right.
And we like, worked up
each other's courage.
Well, we had this plan.
At one point, it was okay,
we're going to go to UNC Asheville.
I'm gonna play basketball,
but they have a film program
and you're gonna.
I'm just gonna keep score. I've done that.
That didn't really come to fruition.
But then it was just like,
okay, are you gonna do what
everybody else is doing
and kind of just go on to
the state school or whatever.
And I said, dad, I want
to go to film school.
He didn't say, don't half ass it, he said,
well, I'm not paying for that.
Heard. Yeah.
But the funny thing is
and we put that in our book,
the Book of Mythicality
we wrote a few years ago,
by the way, Matthew Inman, also
our editor, incredible guy.
Oh yes. Matthew, Matthew E?
Yeah.
Oh, Inman, Inman?
Inman, yeah.
Inman, great and what great hair.
I cannot quit complimenting
him on his hair.
Oh my God, he's got the greatest hair.
And we actually,
we experienced the transition of his hair.
That's true.
Because in book one, he.
I liked to think we inspired it.
It was, it was close
cropped, but book two,
it was a new whole new thing.
Because I put that in
the book and my dad said,
you know, that's not what I said,
you remember that incorrectly.
He was like, I made for a better story.
Right, what did he say?
He said, well, I must
have said something that,
that was what you felt.
Yeah.
And that was the result.
Hey, he and my mom may know each other.
Yeah.
Yeah. I could see into it
that he was not very
supportive of that idea.
So we went to engineering school
and the rest is history.
Yeah.
And it kind of worked itself out,
we took a more circuitous path.
So, you'll you both went together.
Yeah.
Off the same school, engineering school.
And you end back up here
sitting next to each other,
having your platform, a
form of entertainment.
Yeah.
Film storytelling here,
in front of the mic.
Yeah.
So it ended up.
Yeah, we found a way.
Who knows what would have happened.
We found a way, it was
quite a circuitous path,
but I think it turned out
to be the most strategic way for us
to get to where we wanted to get.
We just didn't know that.
I hear you.
So he did us a favor.
Yeah. it's all science looking back.
Yeah.
And history going forward,
but you can connect all the dots,
whatever your dad said, or didn't say,
whatever you felt was
that ain't happening.
So derail and I'm going my own way
and you end up right back and you go,
damn what if he would've said
yeah, I go to film school.
Probably wouldn't work out.
Exactly. Yeah.
Well, one of the things that
we really connected with
and something that's kind
of been on our minds,
relates to your sort of your
very intentional decision
that you made, to say,
I'm not gonna work on
another romcom, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So talk a little,
just for anybody who isn't
familiar with that decision,
kind of gives them
context for that decision.
Yeah.
And then as it relates to your your legacy
is kind of where we want to take it.
Sure, sure.
I think it's around 2010ish
or so maybe a little earlier,
but I'm rolling in romcoms.
I've just done had like four in a row
that have all done well.
Their romcoms are middle
budget, studio pictures.
Meaning at that time is
around $35 million budgets.
It's above the line cost
because you don't have
a huge production value.
It's not, you're not like
making a Chris Nolan film,
where you're spending all
this money on production.
And it's about how the
two, in most romcoms,
how the guy and the girl get along.
It's what the chemistry of them is.
And we know they're going
to meet me at the beginning,
break up for some reason in the middle
and then he'll chase her at the end
and catch her on a bridge
or a moped or something.
And the credits will roll.
We'll be happy, we got there.
Then the fairytale is good.
We've seen it all.
We know it's going to end,
but we just want to see it again
because who are the leads usually in it?
Do we want to follow
them in this love story?
Yeah.
So I've done four of these there.
I'm the romcom guy in Hollywood.
Man, I took the baton from Hugh Grant
and I'm running with it.
That's my lane.
I've got ownership of that lane.
I'm the go-to guy. I like doing them.
They're fun. I call them
Saturday afternoon characters.
So like a flip-flop character.
You don't take romcom.
You don't get in there
and hang your hat on humanity.
No, you're supposed to
bounce from cloud to cloud
and keep them light.
And I believe I did a decent job of that.
Anyway with their success,
they became so successful that
the dramas I did want to do
were I did want to hang my hat on humanity
and see if I could really
flex my active muscles.
The studio system saying no
way McConaughey. no, thank you.
And I say, wait, I'll take a 50% pay cut.
No, thank you.
A 100% paycut. No.
Look, man, I'll do it for scale.
No, we don't want you, you stay.
You're the romcom guy stay over there.
Oh damn it.
Well, that coincides with the fact
that I've now met the woman
who later became my wife,
but I knew I was fell in love
with her very quickly, Camila.
And we had our first child,
she had the child, we
made the child, right?
So I have a first child coming to town.
If you know from the book,
my life's dream was to be a dad, man.
So I'm like all of a sudden,
my life is full and vital.
I get madder,
I get sadder,
I laugh louder,
I have more joy. I'm
talking about meaning.
Okay.
I got meaning in my life, right?
Got you.
My life is not bouncing cloud
the cloud, like a romcom.
So I'm going, Hey, well,
I wish my work could challenge
the vitality of my life,
but it doesn't, oh damn it.
So if I can't do what I want to do,
I'm going to quit doing
what I've been doing.
So I said no to romcoms,
made the call to my money
man, to my agent and stuff.
And I said, I'm not going
to do anymore romcoms,
can you be a keeper at the gate
and hold them back from coming my way.
She had many a tear with Camila
because this drought could be,
I may not work, for I don't know how long.
I may not ever work again in Hollywood.
If I stick to this, which
when I was going to do it,
I knew it was going to stick to it.
So six months go by,
I'm offered nothing but romcoms.
No, thank you.
I think a really fun
story just as I'm going
on my preacher's box now,
and I sound so puritanical.
I think it was a really
nice story to tell you that.
At month eight, without working,
and there was a romcom that came in
with a $5 million offer
and I read it and I said, no.
They came back with an $8 million offer.
I said, no, thank you.
They came back with a $12.5 million offer.
They came back with a $14.5 million offer.
I said, let me read that thing again.
How did it sound at that point?
It was better.
It was better, it was funnier.
It was the exact same words
as the original offer,
but it was a better script.
Oh, yeah, it was.
I get it.
I ended up saying no.
I'd said no to that.
And that I believe in hindsight
was a bit of a turning point.
Meaning in Hollywood,
that's when I think the studios
that were had me on a
list to offer me movies.
That's when they got the message, oh,
McConaughey is not bluffing.
Yeah, he's serious.
He just turned it out for 14.5,
and it's a good script,
but he's not doing it.
So I say no to that.
Then nothing comes in for another year.
Yeah, and you know what.
And we know where it goes,
and I do want to get into that,
but like even pausing at this point, it's,
I think we relate.
Our situation is different,
where we're in a different
world of entertainment,
but we have these aspirations
of being filmmakers.
And then with advent of YouTube.
Yeah.
That was our opportunity.
To develop our audience.
We tried a lot of things before
landing on our daily show,
Good Mythical Morning,
which then became this thing
that was a huge success.
So now 10 years running,
five days a week,
we've been putting out
a couple of videos a day for our show.
Really connecting with our audience.
It's super rewarding.
So much of our career has come
from the opportunities that
that show that we created
and continue to evolve afforded us.
Right.
And now we're sitting
here 44, 43 years old,
continuing to invest and
build a team around this show.
Yeah.
Also doing this podcast,
which is a passion project of ours,
which is doing really great too.
But there's this itch, especially,
I feel like at this point in our lives.
I've got three kids,
Rhett's got two kids,
we've got happily married.
We're living the dream
that we shook with a blood
oath in middle school.
And no matter what Rhett's
dad said or implied.
we found a way to make it happen.
Yeah.
And now we're sitting here
and we've got a lot of gas in the tank.
Yeah.
You built currency.
So I feel like,
I don't want to build
it up as a turning point
or, but I do, maybe it is.
Yeah.
These are the things that
we're wrestling with.
Well, we start asking the question,
In terms of legacy.
Is GMM our romcom, right?
Because it's the thing that, it works.
Yeah.
There's great money in it.
Right.
It's the thing we're known for.
You talk a little bit
about the fear, of sort of,
you can make fear motivated decisions.
Yeah.
But you kind of had to
push that fear down.
Well, you said early,
You said good fear,
the way you feared your dad,
you had a good fear.
Yeah, man. Well, one, congratulations.
You guys are mid-40s, I'm 51.
What do we call this?
It's termed midlife crisis?
Yeah.
Well, whatever, at least
we're got the chutzpah
to lean into some resistance.
Yeah.
Okay.
And at least we got the chutzpah
to question a blind spot,
to question, oh, am I moving?
I'm successful.
And what I'm doing, is it significant?
There's a different,
Hey, also we don't want
to boohoo our romcoms.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Definitely.
Trust me. Remember, when I
was trying to make that choice
and I was still doing the romcoms,
I remember talking to my
great mentor, Penny Allen.
She was like, what is bugging you about?
I go, I just feel like
I'm just an entertainer.
She goes, who the hell
do you think you are
sloughing up being an entertainer?
What do you got against
being just an entertainer.
I was like, thank you.
Put me in my place.
So we have to give the credence,
to what we've done
and not try to make a
straight line crooked.
Yeah.
At the same time,
we want to lean into, wait a minute, man,
is there more here?
And can it still be fun?
Can we still have enjoy?
Because it doesn't have to.
I know what I have to watch is
when things are going,
I love to work hard,
if my work is constructive.
And I feel it working, I don't mind,
if I can break a sweat
everyday, that's fun to me.
I don't like to work hard
and then be frustrated and be,
I don't know where it went,
but...
I have to watch that if it's not hard,
I don't think it's worthy.
And sometimes my easiest stuff,
when you sit there and you tell a joke
and you malaprop the damn thing,
and people laugh at the malaprop
more than they did it at
the real joke, you're like,
oh, geez, that was just an accident.
That was the hit.
Yeah.
We'd go out and we go, I write the book.
I got things in the book that I'm like,
this is going to be the home run, man.
Some of the stuff that
people never talk about that,
it's this other stuff,
and I'm not going, oh.
So I look for it sometimes
to be harder than it should
and I have to balance that.
So how do you lean into the blind spots,
but also not just, like I said,
don't not try to make a
straight line crooked,
not trying to go, well,
it's not hard enough.
This is worked out.
We have to check in with ourselves.
We come from small towns in the south.
I dealt with that, kept my success early.
Like, geez, why me?
I deserve this.
You know what I mean?
Am I breaking a sweat enough?
So, congratulations on the questions guys.
Yeah, and I think.
I'm in them too in my life.
Well, thanks for the congratulations.
We appreciate that.
And we are extremely
grateful for what we've got
and the show is our friendship on display.
And we can sit down behind our desk
and we can just kind of be ourselves
and people are drawn to it.
And we've got great relationships
with our fans because of it.
And it allows us to launch other things
that we want to do, to a certain level.
But then you think about the stories
that we want to tell
and the filmmakers that we want to become.
And there's a bit of a
chip on our shoulder.
You got gratitude on one,
and then I think there's
a chip on the other one.
Sure. Yeah.
It's like, okay, you
guys came up from YouTube
and maybe there's a
little bit of parallel.
When you sent the message to the business
that you weren't even going to
take the $14.5 million offer.
And that really did it.
It's like, we're trying
to find a way to say,
not to our fans, because they know,
but to the gatekeepers to say, hey
we're writing this thing and this thing,
and we gotta get it into
the right person's hands,
or we got to,
we still have things we want
to say and assert ourselves.
And it's different than
what we're known for
and what we're successful for.
Right.
It's a bit frustrating.
What's the frustrating part?
Because you're not sure?
You're not sure. Yeah, go ahead.
Because you've already got,
the fact that you're sitting here,
we have microphones in front of us.
I'm on your show.
Yeah.
You can be heard.
Right.
Even if you want to talk to,
even if you're talking
to those people out there
that may be able to say yes,
let me see what you got, your script,
I wanna maybe finance that.
You already got a huge leg up.
So you're in.
Yeah.
Two things came to mind when
you were talking there is,
and this comes when we're not sure
and being not sure is
obviously very healthy
and true for us to be
maybe sometimes more.
But when it's time to take action,
y'all know you can't be
waiting for permission.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. I know.
You're gonna say a version of effort.
Yeah.
This is what we're doing
by hook or by crook,
and we're not asking permission.
And then it's going to be, probably,
there's a line that I heard
somewhere along my line in life
that I bring up in the book,
that sometimes it's not about
which decision you make,
it just about making damn
one and jumping and doing it
and you find out.
Yeah, should I get off
the pot, kind of thing.
Go fucking find out. You know what I mean?
Yeah. Right.
Yeah.
It's our relationship.
For me, I know a lot of times
it's my relationship with time.
You get a decision like this,
you start thinking, oh man,
I don't know if I am I wasting
time, do I have enough time?
Yeah.
And all of a sudden you look up
and you're 50 and you're going well,
and you're then 55, then you're 60.
Yeah.
When we were 46, why didn't we just go.
Let's see. And plus, and
then what did we find out?
Oh, time is actually on our side.
But if we head into it
without complacency,
you know what I mean?
It's another version of your story.
Not that you're asking my advice on this,
but you've got a show,
are you pitching some of these stories?
Yeah. Yeah.
So I think the way we're
playing it right now is,
really all along the way,
over the past 10 years,
since we've been in LA, we've been,
the business has been built around
what we've been doing online
and that's where we built
our team and our studio.
And that's all working really well.
In the meantime, we've been
like, we've been writing pilots,
we've been writing features.
We're doing that and we
are getting in the rooms
and it's a completely different process.
Over here on the internet, it's like idea
put together the team, execute it,
see what they think about it,
see what the audience thinks about it.
There's no gatekeeper when we get into
the traditional Hollywood thing,
we kind of deal with the
gatekeepers of it all.
Yeah.
So I think we're kind of in a,
let's have our cake and eat it too.
Sure.
But when we both connected with that story
when you were basically like, well,
I'm gonna, and the dynamics are different,
of course, but you were like,
I'm gonna just turn the faucet off.
Right, right.
And they're going to be like,
the only way you get this back on
is if I'm doing what I
want to do specifically.
Right.
And so that's kind of the thing,
that's sort of ruminating right now.
Yeah.
Is like, what does that mean for us?
Right.
Because it's not like, hey,
we're going to stop doing the show.
That's the only way for us
to move to the next thing.
Right.
It isn't as clean as that for us.
But I think that the question,
bringing it back to the idea of legacy
and what you're known for.
Yeah.
I think that's a part of it for us.
It's just like, okay, if
I'm walking the street,
if somebody recognizes me,
it's going to be like
nine times out of 10,
it's going to be from
Good Mythical Morning.
And it's going to be all the episode
where you guys ate the pig testicles.
Or whatever.
And it's just like, okay, that's awesome,
I'm glad that meant something to you.
Do I want the thing that
nine out of 10 people
will remember me for
is eating pig testicles on the internet,
or do I want to be like,
hey, here's the thing that I wanna,
there's a story that I wanna tell.
Right.
So what part of that
for you was like, okay.
Heard.
Well, yeah, I hear ya.
I mean, I hear you.
Look...
our favorite bands
still play their hits at the concert.
Yeah.
You got a pretty good hunch,
it's coming up in the encore.
Yup.
Yeah, you know what I mean.
With good reason.
Yeah.
I understand also,
I'm still introduced to
the first three words
I ever said on film in
1992, in Dazed and Confused,
all right, all right, all right.
Yeah. Right.
Now where there times in my life,
I'm like, really again.
Yeah.
I look back and I go,
geez, I'm glad you didn't
get too upset about that
because you'd have been
dorking out McConaughey,
are you kidding me?
And I switched over to
going, you damn right,
I'm the author of that.
Yeah.
And let me unpack what that means to me.
And it was the beginning of my career
and it's three affirmations
and you're right,
puts a the smile on my face too,
how y'all ride.
What do you mean, am I tired of it?
I wrote it right.
Right.
It's mine, you know what I mean?
I love that.
So grabbing hold of the greatest hit
and going you're damn right.
And I understand why,
it became a greatest hit.
Now, do you go?
Because does the success of
what we're understood to do
and our brand is,
can it be so successful
that it holds other avenues down
for about how we can be heard and seen?
Yeah.
I remember this, Eric Church,
I think he's North Carolina, isn't he?
Is he?
I'm not a 100% sure.
I think he might be, yeah.
Yeah.
But anyway, he came and played
at one of our annual
fundraiser, MJ&M event,
me and Mack Brown,
who's a coach at North
Carolina and Jack Ingram.
And he came and played
and he wouldn't play any of his hits.
He wouldn't?
On purpose. on purpose.
I believe I didn't talk
to him long about it,
but I believe it was about,
no he's in constant creation.
Yeah.
Fast forward before you
get hooked into that.
I think I believe his thought was,
oh, if I keep giving you that,
you're anticipating that
at the end of the night,
and you're not gonna be listening to mine.
He was playing this new stuff,
stuff that wasn't even heard.
And people didn't even know.
And I was like, balls.
That's ball. Yeah
You know what I mean?
But there's another way to look at it.
Again, you don't want
to boohoo the romcom.
You also don't want to boohoo
the all right, all right, all right.
You don't want a booboo
the success of the show.
That's what I mean by don't
make a straight line crooked.
Right.
I like owned own that shit.
Damn right.
You know what I mean?
But... I hear you.
Do you feel like you're being held down?
I can't get this other thing out
that I think is as good or better.
Because he can only be
seen through the lens
of what I had succeeded with before.
Yeah.
I hear you. You know what, again,
I'm gonna go back to that,
don't ask permission.
Yeah.
I like that.
You permission go forward.
And you also,
we have to watch this with
legacy thoughts though, man,
if we are solely based off of projecting
how we want to be seen.
Yeah.
We're not being subjective
and selfish enough.
You know what I mean?
If we can be overly objective,
the idea of legacy project
and to project into our
end go, to our deathbed,
look back and ask ourselves,
what's our eulogy you're going to be,
what are we gonna be remembered for?
Oh yeah.
I think it's an extremely great
thing to do for ourselves,
but we can't live by it.
Or if we live by it, we're gonna miss out.
We're going to look up if we
live to be a hundred and go,
what'd you do the last 50, you
was trying to just get here,
living off of what you thought
the rolling credits were going to be.
Yeah.
I don't know if you know much
about the Enneagram personality stuff,
but I'm an Enneagram three,
which is an achiever, performer.
And one of the things that you do
is you over identify with what
you projected out into the world.
So whatever it is that you
begin seeing people respond to.
Yeah.
So if that was, oh,
well be I'm going to
be good at basketball.
Okay, well, that's the thing,
I'm gonna be the basketball guy.
Yeah.
No, I'm going to be the
guy who plays music,
I'm known to be the guy
who makes YouTube videos,
whatever the arena was.
Yup.
And so, yeah, that's what my therapy
has been about over the past few years.
Sure.
Is learning to find, well,
what does Rhett actually want?
And I do think I've gotten to a place
where it's less about how
do you want to be perceived
and more, how do you
want to live your life?
I mean, that's one of the
things I really admire
about your philosophy of life,
is it's about a life well lived.
It's about living life
to the fullest, right?
Heard.
And I think that this
gets into another thing
that I think that as a good Southern boy,
you can also relate to.
And that is the idea of pairing
a desire for legacy with humility.
Right.
You talk about how to your family,
you're just Matthew, right?
They immediately ground you.
Same exact thing happens either,
my mom will just approach
people randomly in Walmart
and say, do you know Rhett and Link,
well Rhett's my son.
She will do that.
But when I'm with her, I'm just Rhett.
Right.
And there in the south, there's
this ethos of the moment
that you're too big for your britches,
everybody's gonna let you know, right?
So how have you kind of
paired that the idea of legacy
or be an entertainer in general
is that you've got something to say,
writing a book like Greenlights,
you've got something to say
that you think is worth people's time.
How do you balance that with
the concept of humility?
Well, that's a great question.
Because I don't know
about y'all with the idea
and the church that I was raised in.
Humility, to be humble,
to bow down,
to make yourself at least number two.
I can understand it and
get great worth out of it
when I was bending my knee to my God.
But when it came to
society, mortal men, women,
I found that I didn't
know how to be humble
without losing confidence.
And I've found that
when I would be humble,
I didn't know how to be humble.
Those people that are falsely modest
and you're like,
you condescending son of
a bitch, cut that out.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Cut that out.
That's BS.
You're BSing not only me,
but yourself, aah aah.
You know what I mean?
It's like, no, it's that
Renise Sherman story I tell,
hey, she told me I, you know what,
you're really a cute young man.
When I was in ninth grade,
I was like, oh,
she was like, hey,
reached out and grabbed my hand, man.
She was a very good friend
and grabbed my hand.
I say, what?
She goes,
when someone gives you a compliment,
and it's true,
just look them in them in
the eye and say thank you.
Yeah.
Whoa. Yes ma'am. Heard
Now I came across a definition
and I find this very
true for me in my life.
A lot of times it's about
what Webster's dictionary
are we working off of.
The definition of humility,
because I've questioned,
well, you want me to be humble?
Everyone says be humble,
but no one likes to be humiliated.
That's true.
Do you know what I mean, right?
But yet humiliation is an
extension of being humble.
But no,
you ask him, you wanna be humiliated,
everyone's like, no.
But you going to be humble. Yes, please.
Right.
So when I heard this
definition of humility,
as being, knowing you have more to learn.
I was like, oh, that's
the one I'm talking about.
I can go forward and
bow and have reverence
and say please and say
thank you in respect.
But I don't lose confidence.
My shoulders could still be back.
My head can still be high.
My heart can be high.
Because I could admit that, yes,
I've got more to learn, a 100%.
I purchase, I'm in forever.
Different definition and
it made it click for me,
which allows me to be humble,
but still not lose my confidence.
Okay.
Because we know man
confidence is a huge thing.
And I'm a believer in
the necessity of our ego.
We try to pound that down.
If you don't have an ego,
if you don't have judgment,
you got no identity.
You gotta have it.
We've got to have a healthy ego.
We are, everything experience of our life,
no matter how Zen or selfless we are,
it comes through us.
It's the only feeling we can own.
And it's ours and it's original.
That needs to be in capital letters
or in bold print to ourselves.
I think it's a very
true thing to face that
and look in the mirror and go,
that's exactly what that is.
Right.
I know, you know,
I have an opinion that
I know why I succeeded.
I know why I had my hand in
getting what I wanted there.
I know why I had a hand in
failing to get what I wanted,
It's what you get,
whether it's winning or losing.
Well,
it sounds like you're talking about the.
It's really a form of realism, right?
And just being like,
believing the truth about yourself, right?
Well, I am good at this thing.
Right.
That's true.
I need to work on this.
That's also true.
So like more of a self-awareness.
Where you can kind of find your stuff.
Because I mean,
we've all got the imposter
syndrome constantly
and he would show up in a new place,
a new room, a new project, whatever.
You get that imposter syndrome.
But then at the same time,
I usually have two equally,
equal thoughts in my brain.
One is I shouldn't be here
and damn it I should be here.
Right.
You know?
And it's sometimes I can
be a little bit, yeah,
the false humility stuff,
it can be problematic.
But the moment that you
start to think that,
okay, I've got something
to say that is better,
or my story is better than
your story kind of thing.
And it becomes this thing
where I am belittling
or taking advantage of others
in order to get my thing across.
Yeah.
That's when it falls apart.
So I was trying to figure out, like,
when you talked about
making the selfish choice,
I think this helps contextualize that.
Because you did refer to
making the selfish choice,
but I think there's caveats to it, right?
Sure. And look,
self is another word that my pastor says,
I'm pushing a big rock up a steep hill
trying to redefine this one.
All right. Let's hear it.
Well, as you just said it,
when, if it's belittling others,
I don't think it's true selfishness,
in the infinite game, in the law.
If we're really playing the long game
for really trying to create
greenlights in our life,
live a full life, a quality life.
There are sacrifices we make today
to get a larger reward tomorrow.
And someone would say, well,
wait that's sacrificing,
that what you want today right now.
That's very unselfish of you.
I say, no, that's very selfish of me
because I'm going to go
without this dime today
to get my dollar next week.
So if I have any time of
understanding delayed gratification
and quality of life
and I'm considering, hey,
you damn right, I wanna
fill my bank account.
If I consider also I want to fill my soul.
Can I feel my soul's
account alone as well?
In the way I fill my bank account,
I would say that's being more selfish
because what's more selfish,
to get to the end of your life
and go, I just filled my bank account,
but my soul's account was barren.
Screwed people over, burned bridges,
did what I wanted all
the way down the road.
And now I'm here, a alone
SOB, I got no family.
I got broke things out there.
Gosh, I would say that's less selfish.
Yeah. Right.
Because what got what got the bigger ROI.
So it's not in belittling others.
Because I'm with you.
If it starts to be at the expense
of helping someone else out.
Which is that historical sort
of definition of selfish.
Yeah.
Doing things for one's
own, without a relation,
or empathy for any anyone else,
it could be a certain definition.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Right.
I'm actually trying to say,
that the more selfless you are,
the more selfish you are being.
Right.
Any religion says that,
I would also say the more
selfish you are being,
the more selfless you may
actually be being as well.
That they're not a contradiction.
Even the end goal of
every major world religion
is that ultimate personal connection
with the creator or eternity in paradise.
I mean that's kind of
a selfish proposition.
It's a gift.
It's the most selfish proposition.
Even if you're saying, what,
you're telling me I can live a certain way
and get to heaven.
Right.
If you live in that,
that's the ultimate selfish ambition.
Whether if for a believer
who prescribes to that.
In that version,
I would say we have to be more selfish,
but now mind you I'm redefining,
Yeah.
Redefining what that means.
The long game, the
long-term of selfishness.
If you're prioritizing
yourself and your own health,
everyone around you is gonna benefit,
I think is ultimately.
Bingo.
And you're taking trust in yourself,
that's how you trust other people.
Respecting yourself,
that's how you're going to
respect other people more.
And again,
these are just things that
we make a contradiction.
Yeah.
Which I don't believe are,
I believe a much more paradox.
And I think it comes
to light specifically.
I mean, when you were
talking about that juncture,
the non-romcom any more juncture.
And it wasn't just you making a decision,
you said there were a lot of tears
and conversations with Camila
and you you were starting
a family together
and it was a palpable risk.
Oh yeah.
And so it wasn't just
something that you were like,
I want to do what I want to do it.
I mean, so you were,
you were taking into account your family.
I had to look for finances
And they had to be on board.
Yeah. And my wife understood,
she saw my pain and aches and unrest,
at wanting to do roles and have work
that challenged the vitality of my life.
So, as soon as she heard
that coming from in here,
I mean, she was on board with me.
So then she started to squeeze out there
and she goes, she's the one pointing out,
this is gonna be hard.
You don't know how long it's going to be.
You're gonna be dry.
How long you're not going to work.
Yeah.
She also knows well enough
to go at that time going,
you not working, who.
I know how much significance
you get from work,
how much significance you get, Matthew,
from accomplishing things.
How much you like to prepare then finish.
And oh, okay.
I did that. I do, I do, still do.
And she was like, ooh boy, every day,
you're saying every day
could be a Saturday.
Without the structure of work,
the two jobs a year, three jobs a year
that you take that go
for four months or so.
So that could be appealing,
but that could be scary.
Scary as I'll get out.
I've said it before,
the days are long all of a sudden.
Yeah.
I can only tend the garden
and be a good dad and my son for so long.
All of a sudden about
three, three o'clock,
I'm getting antsy going,
I got nothing I'm building in here,
no calls are coming in it.
Start to look up over there and go,
hey, look at that bottle,
hey, might be tight,
well, no it's a little bit early on that.
Okay.
You get restless and to
hold a bearing there.
Luckily I had her and I had a young son
that anytime my mind got off
and I was off in mind,
this monastic sort of sabbatical I was on,
I would look to my newborn
or look to my relationship
or convince myself, trust, trust
the longer you endure this.
Very much like the Australian year.
Yeah.
I clicked into it.
I believe that if you endure this,
there's a greater reward
at the end, Matthew,
trust it, time's on your side.
Getting the best seven,
read some Lord Byron.
I don't want to spoil that whole thing
because I want people to
experience it in the book.
But yeah.
You got a lot out of it.
The least of which is
not a kick-ass punchline.
I mean, with the reveal of it.
But I mean, in contrast to Rhett,
I think when you talk about
like counting the cost
and the risk and looking into the unknown,
when you're at a turning
point in your career,
I think that's the part
that resonates with me.
Yeah.
Because we have so much like, yesterday.
Oh, and I think that it may
have been one of your poems
in your book or it may have
just been something you said.
It gets blurry in audio book
if you're in a poem or not.
Yeah.
Which I actually liked.
I'm like maybe the whole thing's a poem.
But the one when you were talking about,
making love to your
wife earlier in the day
and then having drinks.
Yeah.
And it's like everything
after that, was like,
the dancing was better,
the drinking was better.
Yeah.
All the other things that you do
with the rest of your day.
The spices in the food
were better, everything.
The conversation at
03:00 am across the table
was all better.
Yeah.
It does set a nice stage to
have a good session to begin it.
Yes.
And you know what, yesterday
that happened to me,
me and Christy, we sorted our mail.
Oh, you had morning sex yesterday?
Made a little love.
I had morning sex yesterday
because she was leaving
to go to North Carolina.
And you know what, I was like this.
And then I was like, I'm taking my son,
he's got to have more
driving under his belt
before he can get his license.
We're driving around Los Angeles,
we're driving over the Hollywood Hills.
I'm like son, you are driving
on the Sunset Strip right now.
And then we come back around,
we're going up and it's like,
let's go up to Griffith Observatory.
And then I get back home
and I'm hanging out with the family.
And I went for a mountain bike ride.
I came home.
I said, I'm gonna get in the bathtub.
I got in the bath tub.
And I looked out the window
and I saw the sun reflecting
off the mountains.
Very nice.
And I'm like this,
I feel so secure in this nest.
This is beautiful.
This is a beautiful thing.
And a lot of it had to do
with starting off with
a little love making.
It can open up the aperture.
But it can also trap someone like me
into a sense of security.
Comfort zone.
I don't want to just put it
out there as a wrong choice
because it could be a
right choice for somebody.
I don't know if it is for me,
but I do know I have this
tendency to overvalue security.
And especially when I've got so much,
like that day was,
and there was other things.
If I walked you through all of them.
Yeah, don't.
You'd be like, damn you had a perfect day.
Or I had my perfect day. Okay, so.
Yeah.
But I'm at this point
where we're having these conversations
and I'm fueled off of his being antsy
from a creative standpoint.
I benefit from that to
pull me out of this space
where I'm like,
the risk is scary,
the unknown is scary.
I mean, are there certain things
that you have to drop
to go for what you want
and when it gets to those details
and you're having those
tearful conversations.
I mean, nothing's as scary as I think
when we had nothing
and we were trying to build something.
Right.
So that being said.
Yeah.
I'm still at this point where
looking into that
unknown and saying, okay,
what am I willing to give up to go for
what is still in my tank.
Yeah. Yeah Yeah. Yeah.
Like that you had a passing comment
of when you were positioning everything,
there was a lot of practical steps.
Like you shut down a production company,
I think you said.
Yeah.
You shut down a.
Record label.
A record label.
I'm like, okay, McConaughey
had a record label.
Of course he did.
Yeah.
And then you shut it down.
And it's like, when you feel like
you can do so many things.
It's hard to know what's
the right thing to go for.
Yeah.
Damn right.
But if you look really deeply,
I think that answer's in there for us.
And it's just a question of, okay,
what are we willing to
shut down to open up?
Yeah. I hear you.I hear you.
Do we have a buyers club,
a Dallas Buyers Club in our future?
Right.
I mean, how much could you see it?
How much was it, just foggy?
Yeah, it was hazy.
But the decision,
the truth of the decision to say,
I'm going to sacrifice,
not doing any more of the work
that I'm in pole position to do,
which were the romcoms.
That was clear.
And it was clear to me in solitude.
That was clear to me at 2:00 am, alone.
That was clear to me
at 3:00 am with Camila,
in the dark, without any other noise.
And so the truth of it was clear.
Now the execution becomes the hard part.
Yeah.
And then to trust
that no matter what,
I'm taking this now out into the masses
and the weather's going to get gnarly,
trust that to be true.
Trust that to be believing that
as time goes by and you start to go,
aah, maybe I could amend that.
You know what I mean? Hey, let's go.
But, how secure are you, yesterday?
The morning you had
through with your family,
the morning you had with your wife.
My question is like any good drug, love,
sex, booze, whatever they are.
Fame, attention, the problem's not really
when we're on them, the problem's with
why is it when it comes
hard to live our life
and be secure when we don't have them.
The problem's a week later,
when you hadn't hooked up,
when you're having had that morning.
Why are you a little bit?
Why are you moving a little bit faster?
Why are you not?
Why are you not saying?
Why are you not noticing
that your son's driving on Sunset Strip?
Because you're thinking,
what I got to do here at 11 today?
You're thinking ahead, you're
out of the moment. Right?
Yeah.
So that's a question that I
think is also worth unpacking,
but to get back to,
I think what your your last question was.
You built currency,
you've earned currency.
You're looking at yourself in the face.
You guys are going, we've
earned currency here.
Damn right.
And we know we're responsible for it.
First own that. Then go, well,
I don't want to be foolish with it,
but I also don't want
to be beholden to it.
Right.
So I'm so protective here that I'm going,
hey, we built this.
Let's just be so damn happy
and so damn impressed with what we built.
Let's just fade off and
now maybe we can retire
and go play golf.
I don't know.
It's not what I want to do.
At the same time,
you don't want to take
your currency to Vegas
and just start blindly saying hit me.
Or I fold, without looking at your cards.
So first this, I would go to this
and I've talked about this in the book,
process of elimination.
Before you go to identity.
Before you affirm about
what it is you want to do,
you start eliminating
what you don't want to do.
You were bringing that up.
I started eliminating things
on my proverbial Monday morning desk,
my record company, my development company,
things I was like,
you got these little campfires
and none of them are just flaming big.
There's not enough flame
to really heat the kitchen,
not a flame for Valhalla.
I need to get rid of
a few of the campfires
so I can add more time, gasoline, wood
to these fires that are most important.
Yup.
So then you go, what are
the most important ones?
What are the non-negotiable things where,
what's going with me as I go forward,
no matter what the hell I do,
what am I going to tend to?
What gardens am I tending to?
I'm taking care of
going forward in my life
that are non-negotiable.
Yeah.
For me, I go husbandry
and fatherhood, my family.
That's a non-negotiable
whether I go run for governor
or I go make a rock album.
That's not a negotiable.
Yeah.
So when I look at that and
I try to point those out,
it helps me go, okay, well,
at least we don't have
to wonder about that one.
Yeah.
As I'm going forward,
let's just put that over here in the bag
and say, if I'm going, wherever I go,
this is happening with me.
So it's great to have things,
certain things that are
black and white in our life.
Yeah.
That are not like, well, I'm
not sure that's debatable.
No, that's not debatable.
Right.
Yeah.
I'm not debating that.
It'll help it.
It seems to help, it
doesn't answer the question,
but it does at least lead you in to going,
I find having more in front of you
and ways to pathways to get what you want,
that you go, that could work.
It decreases the amount of options.
Yeah.
And that's a good thing.
Yeah. And I do think that that is,
I'm not going to say it's easy,
but the easy part is making
those identifications, right?
I mean, you can you start
thinking about those fires
and you think, oh, this
fire is not really for me.
This fire somebody said
that this would be a good idea, right?
We do 20 different things
and so you start looking around
and you're like this one seems strategic
because this person said it was.
Then the hard decision
is to just let that fire
or douse it.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's the hard part.
Yup.
How much do we want?
I love it, man.
More ideas. Come on.
I think I can take it.
My biggest asset,
my biggest downfall
and one of my biggest downfalls would be
that I think I can make anything work.
I can be moved and thinks
anything's creative
and anything's like yes.
Yeah,
My biggest downfall
would be the same thing.
My biggest up fall
would be the same thing,
because all of a sudden,
I'm going wait a minute.
You can get too many things.
All of a sudden,
I got all these campfires here.
Yeah.
And I'm inviting more
campfires onto my desk.
I've questioned like in my life now going,
you don't need new fires.
You don't need new ideas.
You need to sculpt what you got.
Yeah.
You need to start framing.
You need to clean up that wood
and get fewer fires, larger flames.
Yeah. But that's good.
Yeah. Because I can
talk myself into an idea
and then by the afternoon,
be convinced that this is the best idea.
Right.
And here's all the reasons
that this is going to work.
But you went, we talk
about our blood oath a lot,
it's fun, but it's so meaningful.
When you wrap things up
and you talk about your top 10 list.
You read it and you didn't have to say
that they had been checked off.
Right.
So what does that mean
for your legacy now?
Like how do you look at it?
Right.
Because that's kind of where
the book ended, but then.
Well, again, I was saying.
You're not done.
No, I'm not done
and some people have said, hey,
you've accomplished all these 10 goals.
Well, no, I haven't.
There was only one I've accomplished.
And that was winning the
Oscar for best actor.
The other nine, my relationship with God,
my relationship as a father,
being close to my parents now,
as my mother's the only one alive,
those with the egotistical utility,
and I'm on the way to succeeding those.
But those are, I have to work on those.
Those are some of my non-negotiables.
Yeah.
If I look at those, I go,
you're gonna be doing these,
you're in process of trying
to achieve these goals
till you leave this earth.
Yeah, right.
Is what I'm convinced of.
So I don't have a new 10 goal sheet.
If anything,
I need to look back at
the original goal sheet
and go, how do we better
tend these gardens?
How do we evolve the
tendance of these gardens,
of these goals that you already have
and not be satisfied.
I still have an
entrepreneur spirit of, hey,
but there's new things, world changes.
But we also, as we know, I mean,
it's Eddie Vedder who said, you can change
by staying the same and
sticking to your modus operandi.
Right.
Your original goals and going, no,
I give that, I'm gonna
still take care of that.
I'm gonna maintain that.
I'm gonna help that grow
and work on that daily.
That changes, you get new ideas,
new things come in our lives.
And we go, uh-oh, we get successful.
We get new opportunities.
I dunno. You know, there's a great,
what would you do with $14 billion?
Someone said,
try to take off five zeros
and do what you do with
$14,000 a million times.
Yeah. I don't know where to move the desk.
But I do know what you're saying. Yeah.
You know what I mean.
And there's real truth to that.
At the same time, we
don't want to be hoarders.
Yeah.
We got success.
We don't want to hoard our currency.
Right.
And say, this is good, I made it
because we know that it's
not a summit we're on.
Right.
We know we didn't get
to the top of anything.
And I think we also got to understand
that there really is
no top, no matter what,
even if you exceed your dreams
that y'all have right now in 20 years,
you're not going to be
there in 20 years going,
we did it.
Yeah, it'll never be satisfying.
You're going to be there in 20 years.
If you succeed, if everything
going, what's next?
Yeah, right. I hope so.
That's just part of the game.
Yeah, that's good to hear,
especially from you,
I feel like we've gone through
the Greenlights workbook
and it's not even out yet.
Yeah.
Well, yeah, because we want
to be mindful of your time.
We could talk to you forever.
We said, this is going to be selfish.
And I think, mission accomplished.
Yeah.
We got some nice McConaughey vibes.
Tell us about the workbook,
which comes out on December 7th, I think.
Yeah, the journal.
Journal.
As you know,
the book is based off
of 37 years' journaling.
Right.
And put out the book.
And I noticed that a lot of people
didn't really journal,
didn't write things down,
but then would talk to me about it,
oh, when they did, it really helped them.
Oh yeah.
So it's a journey.
This is it.
I got little prompts in here, okay?
So there's certain things
for, like, for instance,
I'll kick you off, there you go.
Tell a love story about your family.
All right.
I'm gonna nudge the writer,
where I was the author of Greenlights.
This is so you're the author.
This is your, whoever's got
the journal, it's your story.
I'll be there to guide
you with a couple of,
hey, think about this.
Think about that throughout the book.
So I'm kind of there with you,
but when you write things down,
you're extending the Socratic dialogue.
We have Socratic dialogue all the time.
Yeah.
We think things.
You two can share things.
You've got the bond et cetera.
I have my wife, who I share things with
and other great friends,
but man,
we can say, let's not forget
that the first foremost and last person
that we should be sharing
our thoughts with.
Yeah.
And making obligations
with in contracts with,
is the M and the E, the Y O U.
That's what I'm mean
again, by being selfish,
it's a selfish endeavor
to be maybe more selfless,
to be a better, more truer self,
to be a better person
for more people as well.
And it starts, I believe,
with making our contract with ourselves.
And you never look back.
Exploring ourselves.
You never look back.
Because we've journaled kind of coming up
and you never look back and think, man,
I wish I hadn't recorded that.
I should've journaled less.
Right.
You always think, man,
I wish there was that dry spell
where I just did like
one thing for a year.
And I do think that having that structure
and those ideas to get you started,
it could be super helpful.
Yeah. Very cool.
The other thing I just say is
that journaling has gotten
a bit of a wrong definition,
in that, oh, you go to it
when you're frustrated,
confused and trouble.
Okay. It's good for that.
Don't forget to go to
it when you are rolling.
Yeah.
When you are catching greenlights,
when you are on time and in
line and on your frequency,
dissect your success,
dissect the stuff that
works in your relationships,
in how you started your day
and how you ended your night.
And what worked through the day, man.
Because you will go back.
I've done it so many times
when I then gotten into a rut,
off frequency, lost, frustrated, confused.
I've gone back into my journal and gone,
what were you doing back in June, man?
You had that month. You were just rolling.
Your relationships were
great. Your career was great.
You saw beauty in the world.
I was on tap and I'll go back
and I'll see habits that I had.
Yeah.
That now that I'm in a rut,
I'm going, oh, you quit doing that.
Let's go back.
And it's helped me
recalibrate and go, aah.
Yeah.
And shift me back into my lane again.
And if you need to install
a recorder in your car.
You can do that too, right?
Yes, you can.
I love that idea.
Whatever it takes.
That guy has got a CB to himself.
In his truck.
Yes. DJ.
Well, Matthew man, thanks so
much for spending the time.
Like I said, we're a big fans
of you, big fans of the book.
And I just think that it
totally makes sense that this,
the do-it-yourself
version is the next thing
with the journal. Yeah.
Yeah, write your story.
And you know what,
now that we've heard from you
and had all our questions answered,
we're gonna go for it.
And we're gonna blame
you if it doesn't work.
Awesome. Yes, please do.
All right. Thanks man.
Thanks.
All right then. Thank you.
Call me.
All right.
All right. We just talked
to Matthew McConaughey.
We did.
Remember that, it just happened.
And you know, it was kinda like,
there's just sometimes,
like I said,
we hadn't been talking to anybody,
besides the two of us.
But I kinda just felt like
we just kinda hung out with somebody who.
He's not gonna be your new best friend.
No.
If that's what you're thinking.
Well, I've got something
on the side with him.
That you may not know about,
but no, but I think that
the sort of the rhythm
that comes from and again,
I don't want to make it seem like, yeah,
we've got the same life
experiences Matthew McConaughey,
as you'll get from that book, man,
the dude has lived this crazy, crazy life
where I've never had a
dream about some place
and then traveled there.
Twice.
More than once in my life.
Yeah.
I haven't done it at all.
So, but I do think
that was a very beneficial
conversation for two of us.
Yeah.
I think there's no magic bullet,
it's not like, okay, I'm gonna do this
because he said this phrase
and everything clicked into place.
But the way that he presents
his life of stories in the book
is very inspirational.
It's like when in doubt, go for it.
Have the experience,
embrace the experience
versus finding excuses to not do it.
Of course, that can't
be a blanket statement
across the board, but it's inspirational
and a great reminder that
like going for something
and being up for the experience of it
harbors so many rewards
that you can expect.
And also chasing who you truly are
and your passions is something
that really resonates.
And I think a lot of people,
a lot of our fans may think, oh,
it feels like you guys
have lived a life that is,
leaning into risk and trying new things.
And I know that there is a part of that
and some significant points in our career
that are kind of characterized
by that mentality.
But I think that the way
that we perceive ourselves
and our critical analysis
of the way that we operate
is that we err on the side
of being too practical.
Yeah.
And we end up being too reasonable
and we make decisions
that make too much sense.
And I think that there is a part of us
that wants to ask the question, well,
what would it be like if fill in the blank
with an impractical question or decision.
Because the fact is,
and it's hard for me to see it and say it,
that we are in a position
where we could go after things
based on the success that we have
and the relationship that
we have with Mythical Beast.
So there's still a lot
to think about there.
And we'll continue to,
we won't keep talking about it forever,
But whose wreck is it?
Well, I think that whoever's, it is,
we know what we're wrecking.
I've already wrecked journaling.
Now I can say, and if you
want Matthew McConaughey
to give you thoughts starters,
well, there's a journal for that
that's coming out soon,
Greenlights journal.
But yeah, listen to Greenlights.
Yeah.
If you like good stories.
And I would say now we both listened to it
and it's an incredible audio book
because I mean, it's Matthew McConaughey.
So, you know, that the way that
he's going to McConaughey it
when he delivers, is going
to be worth your time.
I will say we also do have
the physical copy of the book.
And a lot of the things
that he talks about,
complete with pictures and
bumper stickers, et cetera,
a lot of that stuff is in there.
So I think it's,
choose your poison,
but both of them are great.
And there's a reason that
it's reverberated so widely,
over the past year or
so, since it's been out,
We are leaving on trips,
independent of one another.
Me and Christy are going
on a trip to Big Sur,
and I'ma go into Key West.
Oh man.
Never been there.
Never been to that little.
Key.
Little.
Whatever.
Thing that Florida pooped
out at the end of itself.
It's like the dribble of pee
from the penis that is Florida.
Oh gosh, you should have
saved that for your intro.
That's what we'll be talking about
next week on Ear Biscuits.
But you know, #EarBiscuits
let us know what you think
about this conversation.
You probably have some thoughts
about how good is the ego.
I don't know exactly if
I agree with him on that,
but maybe some of it is semantics,
but get into whatever
you want to #EarBiscuits
We'll be here next time.
On the flip side of our trips.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget
to click on the circular
icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.